you said that you felt the connection
with justin right away uh what was it
about him maybe his work
um that impressed you
um well i i had seen his i had kind of
followed his career especially since i
saw coming out of sundance a few years
back
i kind of i was amazed to see and this
was also something that he told me was
the reality when we first had a chat you
know the fact that you know he was in a
situation in life where he's an american
citizen and he's a great actor and has
proven that but because he has korean
parents uh it was tricky for him to get
work you know i hope we live in a world
where that is about to change but he's
you know he's so driven so he made he
said well then i just had to write it
and direct and act it myself and i was
so amazed he's an incredible filmmaker
and after i saw that film he was
definitely on my radar and when i had
read the script for blue bio we got you
know on uh
on a
phone call chatting i was you know um he
is
so incredibly driven and passionate and
very intelligent
and i just loved hearing about you know
the thoughts he had why he wanted to
tell the story and how he wanted to
present you know
to me a very you know it's a very
problematic issue obviously what i love
with his filmmaking is that he always
finds a way to show the beauty even in
the most tricky situations or or the
most harsh environments um yeah
yeah what's what's so
um at the forefront of this which makes
it so heartbreaking is the relationship
of that family and the love that is so
clear that these characters have
um what was it like for you where did
you go to find the core of kathy to be
able to show
you know to show the audience what the
heart of this family is
i think you know um and justin said this
too he when we first had a chat he was
like yeah because he had seen actually
my first film i had ever made a swedish
phone call international title called
pure and he said is that where you come
from and i was like yeah he was like
it's interesting because maybe we all
saw in the beginning of your career you
had a british accent because you did
some british movies and you played like
royals
and queens and stuff and he was like
you're kind of from you know a very
simple
working class background in a small town
with a single mother you know in a
studio flat in sweden
and i was like yeah so if anything
i probably feel more connected to the
kind of
family and and how much it means to be
you know a very driven hard-working
parent or partner in in life and and i
admire people like antonio and and kathy
and have seen them
around myself even though it's been on
the other side of the world in sweden
that kind of
core
um drive and and and
and respect for family i think it's the
same
um yeah so i kind of i love that this
film you know uh gives the chance to
tell
the the story of a
of individuals and family that sometimes
don't get the light shined upon them